there's so many people that don't
believe a rising tide floats all boats
they see it as socialism that's what the
response is to Bernie Sanders and what
Bernie Sanders is saying what many
people are saying is the two can coexist
we have the ability to be capitalists a
true capitalist wants everyone to have
access to great schools because more to
to capital because the more access the
more people the more ideas the more
competition the better the ideas and the
growth will be so the idea of growth
comes from the more people participating
in it we have gotten away from the idea
of true capitalism now we have people
who claim to be capitalist saying well I
want to restrict our resources that we
have a finite amount of resources so I
got to make sure only my kids get
opportunities at school but we're only
going to have access to capital that my
tax breaks are going to be here and at
the expense of other folks and that's
actually not true capitalism we grew as
a country when people say hey listen
it's important that everyone has access
to a good education it's something of
great importance because that means more
people that are educated the more ideas
the more growth we're going to have and
that's what capitalism is based on and I
go back to art music it's what jazz is
all about it's an American aesthetic is
freedom within form yes there's
confinement and restriction and
technical proficiency but the idea of
the jazz solo as an improvisation is a
finite amount of notes with an infinite
amount of combinations a finite amount
of notes with an infinite amount of
combinations and so that's what
capitalism is right there's an
ultimately an infinite amount of
possibilities with this finite group of
people but the more people that are in
the mix the more ideas that are going to
come about which produces growth that's
what jazz music is
you know freedom within form within this
confinement I still understand that I
have a possibility to find my you know
true north my creative spirit my
infinite ideal
you